si sin lugar a dudas en lugar a duda yo
creo cotton y el él ya venía teniendo
acercamientos no confirmados pero lo que
se sabía en el mundo era que ya tenía
intentos de acercamiento eso va a
significar que él va a pagar más o menos
unos cinco a seis años de cárcel y luego
va a volver algunos jefes paramilitares
y narcos vuelven y son asesinados otros
vuelven y no tienen mayores dificultades
desprendiendo la cantidad de gente que
de los que señale no se delate por
cooperar con el narcotráfico pero hay
allí ambos ejemplos pero en teoría yo
creo que no va a tener problemas tener
la primera vez que se somete a la
justicia ya estuvo sometido la
movilización paramilitar y volvió a
reincidir aquí es posible que vaya a
eeuu españa y ya y después regrese a
colombia